hello and welcome to this video playing
Leon 28 Rafael Mendoza okay yep rustling
noise very popular this is the line that
I had on the board recently in one of my
blitz games and then he's four and was
extremely solid for Wyatt it usually is
oh here Bishop g4 I can play not sure
that it's desert and it makes me much
but sometimes you're struggling a bit to
find something good to do for your light
squared Bishop and quite often place an
early age three okay yeah I don't have
to worry about this okay I can try to
put some pressure on the pawn right
before is also interesting just trying
to be annoying there on the pond okay
no I don't really have any pressure
there I maybe I had cc4 maybe but ok Len
denied what was unprotected so see form
not work but something that might work
with some prep was in playing f4 I know
that that mover had not thought of it
all f4
nice got 94 after that and my night
still is hanging
[Music]
f60 might play a five I should play a
five-year stop him from playing 94 it's
actually very logical move but Tim took
me ages to come up with and that looks
that looks okay ready for me so CY again
doesn't work I don't know epon 26 I
think the night it's a good square for
the nite nite a six over here you can go
to see for I can always kick him out
with be five
even then immediately five interesting
yeah it looks good I mean this is it
this is a good position I look a 8 and
you can try to play them so 94 now on
another move that is quite interesting
is something with g5 but it's probably
Ted Earley and this concrete situation I
bring the Queen over there I probably
should have gone to the five anyway wait
wait wait wait i have bishop here
provoking g3 would be nice okay put the
Queen here
and it's not threatening to place you
for I think still yeah maybe h5m ok this
is I'm stopping Ruby I cannot take yes I
cannot take it if I take you might take
94 like you might take it yeah that's a
very tough new growing game him Jeff
Jeff time warning you be down on time
Jay
and I'm a bit I really really really
really really miss played that that
ending started as good for black and
turned sour at the very beginning our
I'm totally fine and here I'm obviously
not fine ok said winning e64 white was a
bit better might still win of course
shoulda played e6 that would have been
very easy with easily winning this I
mean yes to take and try to invade them
but maybe a fortress yeah it is it is
not holding because of Bishop f8 at the
end okay black resigns Marilyn extremely
extremely unnecessary loss the beginning
of this ending I should not ever do was
ready okay okay he has before I mean
with what I meant with I was fine at the
beginning of this ending it means like
roughly here I know it's no ending but a
thought here should be completely fine
many plates and you didn't do anything
really
couldn't fit age 5 and so on until gave
me da file I mean can probably you
cannot do much but okay I should maybe
keep it on the border this before idea
is a big problem I just need one or two
moves to sort the profession and I
didn't didn't get them okay yeah this is
this is very unpleasant probably losing
King be sadness however tough I am
hoping for this over way I'm completely
fine and now I'm I'm losing me not
laying not playing success pretty awful
because that wins very easily but the
position is so bad that even this is
winning it's funny that the engine gives
t6 with white winning which is of course
completely dead wrong that's completely
dead computers their Wi-Fi is of course
completely winging it took a while check
at the end he figured it out I cannot
cannot do anything there hmm yes so
where I'm not quite sure I mean it's
probably just equal I'm looking for
things that are not there and I can
probably be equal by just playing
unofficially like not even trying to do
things of course I had overlooked that
c4 was actually possible my plan was to
put something on d4 next move and that
never worked out
after see for now I couldn't get this
going oh ok thanks for watching